la crise center à quoi aider le
gouvernement legault a accumulé les
pires déficits de l'histoire du québec
alors que nous avait promis aux premiers
qui avait balancé le budget c'est lui
qui a fait augmenter la dette le plus
vite dans l'histoire du québec le
portrait des finances publiques est il
aussi sombre que le laisse entendre éric
duhaime
non la réalité est beaucoup plus nuancée
c'est vrai que le québec a déclaré un
déficit historique en 2020 2021 qui a
dépassé les 10 milliards de dollars on
était alors au pire moment de la
pandémie mais il a été entièrement
épongés avec la réserve de stabilisation
qui est en quelque sorte un compte en
banque pour les imprévus
si on fait abstraction de cette année là
qui a été exceptionnel
depuis l'arrivée au pouvoir de la cac le
québec a connu des surplus budgétaires à
tous les ans avant les versements
effectués au fonds des générations qui
sert à rembourser la dette ce qui est
important c'est le poids de la dette on
est rendu à 36 points 4 % du pib puis on
prévoit que 10 à 20 du mandat on va ta
35.8 puis d'ici 10 ans est à 31 donc
l'important c'est graduellement de
réduire le poids de la dette selon la
majorité des économistes c'est en effet
le poids de la dette par rapport à la
taille de l'économie qui est la
meilleure mesure de l'endettement des
états
la dette continue de grimper d'année en
année au québec mais l'économie croît
plus rapidement en ce moment la dette
nette est de 192 milliards de dollars et
représente 38 % du produit intérieur
brut dans cinq ans on prévoit qu'elle
atteindra 206 milliards environ 32% du
pib un fardeau qui sera donc moins lourd
à porter